Didn't like the earlier ones.
He's older.
It's all marine,
which is supposed to be right.
If his body can recuperate from anything.
Why the fuck the aging?
Exactly.
Come on.
Why is he agent like that?
Stanley come on where he's losing some of his muscle,
but he's still throwing people to the air.
They're talking about he gets shot,
recovers right away,
but it's fucking joints hurt his arthritis.
What's happening to the arthritis?
No.
You'd really moved like it these days.
I don't know if he officially does.
I'm just saying it doesn't make sense.
How about to come out with another fucking Spiderman?
Oh,
thank God.
They need a new Spiderman.
They never want to pay Peter Parker.
When Peter Parker's starts getting big,
they go,
yeah,
well guess what?
We're going to reboot it.
I just keep playing voting it.
They keep telling the same story over and over again with subtle differences.
My spidermans Tobey Maguire,
you fuck you fuck take rocks.
Uh,
tell you what though.
The only time that that's worked though the hawk.
Yeah,
they've done it.
Okay.
They started off with that Australian dude from chopper.
What's his name?
Eric Bana.
He was number one,
wasn't thrilled about him as the hawk,
not his fault.
It wasn't his fault.
It wasn't the best managed script and then I had Norton pretty good as a hawk
fan of Ed Norton.
I was like,
okay,
I can buy this.
But then mark refollow best hawk,
best home,
I believe him.
I believe he's really a scientist too.
I really believe he really understands genetics.
You know like Christian Bale is the best Batman.
You're talking about real act.
I agree.
Sorry,
Ben Affleck.
I agree.
How about Michael Keaton was Batman.
Who the fuck that was a good guy.
Dan Batman high cast.
Michael top about this.
George Clooney's Batman too.
He's a fucking Mr. Steal your girl.
I bought George Clooney.
I brought,
I didn't buy for a second.
Oh,
when Jim Carrey was the Riddler and then Tommy Lee Joint Jones was to phase.
Those are the best Batman when they were like,
oh,
we need to make this more real.
I'm like,
fuck you.
I liked Arnold Schwarzenegger's Mr. Freeze.
Wait a minute.
Who was the Riddler?
Jim Carey was the Riddler.
When?
Who Was Batman?
Uh,
George Clooney.
No Batman returns.
Broan wow.
But Christian Bale's Batman forever.
Sorry.
Christian Bale's it better that it's too real.
Do you know Christian Bale was Batman only like six months after he was the
machinist.
That's insane.
Yeah.
I got sue really insane.
He would be down to like almost nothing.
He was dying.
He was eating like a can of tuna and an apple a day.
That's insane.
Kind of willpower.
You have to have to let your body literally rot away to this skinny thing for a
movie.
Just for a movie.
You don't have anorexia.
You don't have a disease.
How much you loved the craft of act and to do.
Yeah,
man.
Yeah.
Everybody trying to be the drug to these days though.
That's like the big one.
Tony Hinchcliffe.
He's tries to be,
excuse me,
Tony.
Tony wants to be the joker.
Yeah,
look,
so look,
he went from that to that one 21 to one 95 that's all natural.
That's insane.
There was another movie in between,
I think equilibrium.
It said there's not a picture of here,
dude,
you're telling me that's not photo shopped at all on the left?
No,
no,
no.
That's what it really looks like.
That is so unhealthy.
Oh Dude.
It takes years off your life.
I mean,
you're putting unbelievable stress.
He organized,
he's a beast.
He's English.
You know that.
I thought he's Australian.
He is.
He thinks so.
I thought that this act really English bro.
A lot of them are Australian.
They'll,
they'll throw you for a loop Jack,
but Jackman like as an actor,
like Christian Bale at your words.
He does some stuff.
Wolverine night.
Look,
I'm a fan.
Don't get me wrong.
Um,
but Christian bale does some stuff like in American psycho.
Okay.
That's another one.
Dude,
he was in the fighter when he put,
when he played a Micky ward's brother.
Oh my God.
Dude.
Up and down the whole time when 85 201191305145 him and reign of fire,
he is bodied the fuck up.
So he got down skinny again to play a Micky ward's brother and meth addict.
Yeah.
Yeah,
I forget.
Mickey wears his brother,
but his brother fought sugar ray Leonard.
Yeah.
This is like between two rescue dogs and we saw that one fucking beast.
That dragon movie was dope for one of them.
Silly dumb movies.
Which Dragon Movies in a dragon movie.
What was the dragon movie he was in?
Was It in dragon movie with Matthew mcconaughey?
If it was uh,
it was in the future.
Yeah.
The everybody had to live underground drugs.
I did them all.
They had to live Raina fire.
Oh,
of fire.
Yeah.
That's the drag number.
That's a reign of fire.
Oh Damn.
There's a dragon movie.
Yeah.
Matthew Pecan Hayes jacked in that movie.
Oh Man.
Super jacked to see.
He got Super Skinny for Dallas buyers club when he had eight.
Yeah,
he did it too.
He's another one.
Yes.
See if you get a picture of Matthew mcconaughey jacked dude.
I heard rumors about Tom Hardy shirtless take when Matthew mcconaughey shirtless
reno fire.
See right there,
that picture was got a vest on.
Look out Jackie.
Looks Damn.
Yeah.
He was jacked for this moment for her to that movie.
Not Math.
It's a dumb movie.
Is it?
Is it bad?
It's just dumb.
It's entertaining.
It's silly.
You know that these dragons,
fuck everybody up and you know,
dude,
remember how bad I used to hate on dragons till I watch game of Thrones down on
all you guys for watching.
I watch game of Thrones.
That dragon burns.
Spoiler.
You fuck's been up for nine years.
He Burns that fucking frozen wall.
I'm talking about standing ovation.
I was in the middle of my living room.
Slow clap.
Those dragons are fun and scary that when they,
the one turns into a fucking white walk.
Yeah,
yeah.
Ooh.
Make a card.
It ends in is I just feel,
and it's a white walker,
I,
everybody who works on that show,
listen to me.
Don't ever cancel it.
Just keep going.
It's all just,
you're never going to do anything better than that.
Now that's the greatest show of all time.
I know.
I don't know what you're thinking.
Just write some new episodes.
Figure out some new shit.
The greatest show of all,
they just rap.
No,
they rep.
there'll be back.
Got Damn.
Look at that.
Miss Jana.
Matthew mcconaughey,
jacked Jack.
I feel like for me to get that skinny and thin,
I would have to go on some,
I'd have to get some roll like Dallas buyers club and blew it up one right above
that.
Right above that.
Right above your cursor.
Right,
right there.
I'm on different,
Oh,
who's that?
That's Bradley Cooper.
Cooper bodied up to son.
Look at him,
but wouldn't you get do all of the steroids to play these roles?
I think they called me to be Batman.
I'd like a,
all right,
let me get down a gold's gym.
See you.
I can do,
yeah,
you would have to.
You'd have to.
You'd have to go on the carnivore diet.
Drop your body fat down.
I wouldn't you though.
Yeah.
Intermittent fasting.
Just the whole cryo every day.
Yeah,
you would.
You'd be training camp,
get shredded,
be training camp.
You would want to have that scene.
What you're putting on your fucking outfit and you're just talking odd like we
need more scenes where I'm sure it lists town downtown bullshit.
Oh,
Ryan Reynolds.
Ryan ramp.
Is that Ryan?
That's blade blade blade three.
That's Ryan Reynolds and blade three.
Well,
who is that guy that's,
oh no,
that's next level.
See if that's what you got to try for.
That's what you gotta try for.
No one ever tries to that.
Do chicks don't dig that though.
Take fucking shot.
Take that shot.
They say that because they're trying to make you feel better.
Oh my God.
I think it's so gross.
I like geysers soft.
I liked it.
Grab your back and fill up fat.
Look at Ryan Reynolds with this.
Fuck no bro.
Pack.
No.
Oh my God.
It way.
I mean,
I definitely don't want his dick in my mouth.
A little belly fat on my nose.
Full rack of ribs now fuck in the shake.
Once we're done with this shit,
man.
He was just relax like me and doesn't want to deal much.